That's what, when I first met you,
that's what I got from you have a really good childhood.
I think it's unbelievable. It's unbelievable. My bonds are incredible.
My parents are absolutely.
Very actualized and you really have a lot of the things that neither here I have
act like you, you,
you can get there and you can rally for yourself and you have that belief in
your own power. We're we're spineless little, um, um,
kind of scared of our own. Um.
Or they say, I don't believe that the worst finally schools,
I don't believe that you guys don't believe in your power.
No came. Cause we got beat so much as children.
It's like every, you know,
we never really were rewarded for even anything.
Yeah. Ah, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
Because how can you become so successful? What is it?
Or do you not recognize your own success?
Unless there's, I, I have a perfectionist, a perfectionist kind of head.
I won't even try if I don't know. The result is absolute perfection. Yep.
Because it's not like there's any reward to be had because I just was never
rewarded unless it was exactly what my.
And then that's crippling. Right.
Cause then you don't try to do certain things because you might end up here.
Yeah. So eventually you just become paralyzed with all these,
like an abundance of ideas. You'll never ever even pull the trigger on.
No, that is interesting about it now,
but we're but that's why I have tasted success. Yeah. And I'd be like,
I look at a guy like you though. And I go, um, cause we really are fond of you.
I love it. Thank you. I love it. I love you. I mean, I love you, but I know,
I know. But as soon as I met you, I was, I was fond of you and I think,
you know, rogue and all these people with you too. Right. It's just like,
you know, you're able to now do bi-coastal, right? Yeah. You guys,
you guys have embraced me more than the New York scene has embraced me. Wow.
Really a hundred percent West coast embraced me way before in New York.
That's so strange. Um,
I kind of like carved my own path in New York.
Like I didn't like do like the traditional, like, uh,
I wasn't like hitting the mix with a lot of people and I wasn't like for lack of
a better term,
like really kind of like hanging around maybe the seller and like, um,
I don't want to say kissing of the OGs, but like, uh,
I just didn't feel like that was the best use of my time.
Like I thought the best use of my time was like getting on stage as much as I
possibly could and being as funny as I possibly could, you know?
And like that's what my main focus was. And I,
I wasn't like trying to like cozy up to anybody to like open for them.
And maybe that was interpreted as like not, you know,
paying the respect or something like that, but that's never what it was.
There's just like, I know what the I want to do. And I know how to get,
I can get better at comedy by working on comedy,
not by telling this comic how amazing his set was. Does that make sense? Yeah,
but I, but you know, for me, um, my opinion about somebody is,
you know, I look at the work. Hmm. Okay. So it's like, you know, when I,
I remember when I first met you, I don't know if I said this is the last time,
but I didn't know who the you were. Right? Yeah.
I had heard your name because I knew that you were on the list.
Cause we're doing that show together. Yeah.
But it couldn't put a name to the face.
So you were leaning against this like pole, right. And you go, Hey, I'm Andrew.
And what I wanted to say, I didn't say it. I don't give a. Right.
That's what I wanted to say. But I go like, Oh,
nice to meet you Andrew or whatever, this white guy. Right.
But as soon as you know what I mean, he, he, I saw him perform right there.
It's the same feeling that I had when I saw Patrice for the first time. Oh,
that's the biggest compliment where I went, Oh.
That's real. Right. He could be the biggest piece of. You know? I mean,
hopefully I could be his friend. He was a piece of. I can't be his friend.
Right. But then the, he turned out to be a really nice guy as well. Right.
But it's like, I just look at the work. Right.
I don't know about the history or how you got there. You know,
I look at what I see on stage and I go, Oh, that's high level.
Right. Yeah. And so, um, that's how I, you know, that's how we've,
that's how I know you. Right, right. From, from the work and that's the best.
Yeah. You know, and, and now, you know what I mean?
You're also a great podcaster and we, we have a good relationship, but um,
you know, I really do, you know, you're a young kid. I want to hurt you.
Sometimes. I really do. When I look at the videos, you know what I mean?
I want to go, I don't want to get, but I have to with that. Thank you, man, man.
with it. So when's the Netflix. When is it? It's out. Yeah. It's out now.
It's a, you guys should go check it out. Man. Is a Schultz. Saves America.
That's what it is. Yeah. And then what else do you have going on? Nothing
[inaudible] stand up or no, I haven't done any actually I have. Yeah.
And weirdly enough, I haven't desired it. Yeah.
I think like my creative juices were fueled by this project that just took so
much time. It was okay. And then weirdly enough,
like doing pods, like in hanging around, not my own pod,
but like doing other people's pods,
especially if there's like people in the room,
I start to miss stand up a little bit.